will she be a series regular for season
five that much she tell us that let me
just tell you right now we're like yeah
I care instead I want to go so badly I
haven't been told if I'll be going but I
would love to go I've been many times
before
oh really for other four I think we
mostly just for black sails cuz they're
definitely being on flashes a lot of
pressure just because it's been on for
so many seasons already so I definitely
I think more of that was like fitting in
into the world I wanted to feel like I
fit in and then kind of be accepted by
the fans there definitely was that but
and not on the same level as like hey
everybody it's Charlie this is gonna be
my video all about Flash finale as well
as the arrow Tommy episode I'll talk
about Flash verses because of all the
coffee girl stuff obviously the actress
Jessica Parker Kennedy just did a recent
interview so I included a couple clips
from that there's a little bit more that
I'll include later in the video too but
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos we're getting ready for a couple
big finales there's a flash ring
giveaway that's going on all you have to
do to enter that just be a subscriber
leave a DC related comment on the video
so the cool thing about the finale is
they release the synopsis they confirm
the title as we are the flash we
actually heard about that a long time
ago that that's what the finale would be
called but this is them just confirming
that is his team flash gets an
unexpected Ally in their fight against a
vote me that Marlies who recently left
tuvo is probably going to help them out
but also coffee girl is going to tee up
their season 5 art so they'll get help
from Marlies and defeating tuvo they'll
also get some help from coffee girl
that'll have something to do binding the
mystery speedforce symbols that barry
was writing at the beginning of this
season that also show up in des Vosges
book on his blackboard in the ones that
coffee girl is writing brand new the
producers also said that there will be
two big teasers for next season in the
finale one will be coffee girl herself
just like revealing who she is and how
she's important to the season 5 plot but
also who the big villain of season 5 is
going to be implying that it's not going
to be coffee girl which I feel like is
confirmation that she's not going to be
some mystery version of the
reverse-flash wearing someone else's
face so if you were one of those people
who was
acting that theory I feel like that's a
big strike against that so whoever the
villain is going to be is gonna be
someone completely different but because
people have been asking me this after
they released that description who do
you think the villains going to be I'm
gonna wait till we actually get a couple
more episodes before saying who I think
it could be like these are the top five
people that it could possibly be because
there are a couple obvious picks for
characters from the future implying that
coffee girl is gonna have some tie to
whoever the villain is and she's from
the future it means the villain is also
probably somewhere from the future there
are a couple big characters the flash TV
show has not done yet that they could
cherry pick for that villain but like
the TV show changes things I think it'll
be an amalgam of a couple different
comic-book characters and ideas so
that's why I'm gonna wait a couple more
episodes before I list my picks for
season 5 villain but they made it sound
like the teaser that they'll give us in
the finale will be pretty obvious so it
should narrow it down pretty quickly
once we get that episode but the other
cool thing about this is that Jessica
Parker Kennedy the actress was asked in
her little QA will you be a season 5
regular and obviously she couldn't
answer that even if she knew but she
also answers a question about comic-con
that makes me feel like oh yeah she's
definitely coming back next season
because she also says they haven't told
me whether or not I'm coming to
comic-con I really hope that I get to go
because I like doing that kind of stuff
implying that she will be coming back
and if she's gonna be a big part of
season 5 in some way then they would
want to bring her to comic-con and she's
just not sure what the comic-con plans
are because a lot of networks wait till
the last minute to announce what those
are but think about it this way if
they're gonna come to comic-con and hype
up season 5 if she was one of the
biggest talking points of season four
they would be making a huge mistake in
not bringing her along too she just
feels like an early fan favorite walking
away from season four like what did you
like most oh I love the idea about copy
girl I mean a lot of that will depend on
the way they stick that landing like
there's still a couple of left turns
that they could take with that so
hopefully everything goes well with the
last couple of episodes and everyone's
at least a little bit satisfied with the
reality of who she winds up being but as
we get more footage we'll be able to
narrow the theories down so I feel like
going into the finale
will have a pretty solid idea of who she
is like we pretty much knew going into
the last episode of season two of the
flash that Jay Garrick was gonna be the
reveal underneath the iron mask so just
think about it in those terms they
actually tease stuff pretty openly going
into the finale so we'll just get some
more evidence in the next couple of
episodes we'll see how it goes down but
here's the thing about the season 5 plot
for flash once we find out who she is
absolutely and once we know who the
villain is or at least have a good idea
of who the villain is then it'll be a
lot easier to predict about what their
season 5 arc is going to be based on the
comic book history of those characters
as well as the history of how the show
treats those comic book storylines like
they did the thinker this season but
they changed a lot about it you use that
as a template to treat how they do other
comic book stories but moving into arrow
territory so arrow is a week ahead so
that means their finale is gonna air the
week before the Flash's finale but they
had a big Tommy episode we finally found
out how they brought him back and it
turned out to be human target pretending
to be Tommy
please state your name for the record
Thomas Merlyn Tommy's fine if you want
so it was Colin Donal coming back for
this scene here pretending to be human
target pretending to be earth one Tommy
so his performance like if you went back
and watched an arrow season one episode
with Tommy in it his Tommy would feel a
little bit different because it's
supposed to be human target pretending
to be Tommy it was a really fun idea I
mean it was a trial episode it was very
much like the trial of the flash and it
kind of played out the same way - with
the big twist at the end where they
wheel someone in pretending to be
someone else that gives them evidence
that lets them off they also just
announced that Paul Blackthorne is
leaving the show at the end of this
season implying that he might wind up
being a casualty of the finale because
usually finales either a killer
character or there's some big emotional
turn it feels like they're gonna use
Quentin this season for that on arrow
it'll have something to do with black
sirens Redemption art because all
through the back half of the season he's
had these scenes with her where he says
you need to stand up for yourself be
your own person even though they
acknowledge that she's not his version
of Laurel they kind of treat her that
way the fact that she openly defied Diaz
and protected Oliver and then tried to
go take down Diaz before he could
retaliate against her maids it seemed
like she's definitely going to be an
ally to team arrow during season 7 I
don't think there's any chance they kill
her in the finale I think that Quentin's
probably going to be the one to die he's
probably the person in the hospital bed
in the picture that Stephen Amell posted
from the finale a while ago we all
thought that it was someone else but now
it might wind up being Quentin in that
hospital bed but the other really
important thing that they did in this
trial episode is that they spent a
couple of different scenes clearing
Roy's name remember he took the fall for
Oliver and said that he was the hood so
that Oliver wouldn't go to prison then
skip town so he's been a fugitive from
justice this whole time so because he's
going to be a series regular next season
he'll be coming back to team arrow they
had to find a way for him to be able to
walk around in broad daylight without
being arrested on sight
so Oliver had a scene when he was on the
stand saying that Roy took the fall for
the hood Roy is not really the hood so
he should be exonerated of that they
separately when thick Tommy dropped in
he also said the same thing
Roy Harper confessed to being the hood
to protect me and then he was attacked
in prison I have lived with that guilt
for three years so if it wasn't clear
Tommy is still dead on earth one this is
Christopher chance
aka human target pretending to be Tommy
who also then later pretended to be the
judge when he overturned the jury's
ruling so the next two episodes on arrow
is the war between Diaz like declaring
war openly against Tamara going after
all their families and everyone and then
resolving that in the finale two more
episodes of arrow so it's gonna be done
in a couple weeks but leave all your
questions in the comments I'm sure
there's gonna be a whole bunch more
coffee girl teasers for the flash and
we'll find out a little bit more about
arrow season 7 as we get closer to the
finale will be a whole bunch more Marvel
posting tomorrow I will name a new
giveaway winner when I post new DC click
here for my flash episode from this week
and click here for that brand new
Deadpool trailer thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight